from Turner Sports the exclusive home of
the NBA all-star game in 2020 from
Chicago the all-star captain's and
starters revealed tonight at 7:00
Eastern Time and a special one-hour
pregame show followed by the double dip
of Lakers Nets Mavericks and Trail
Blazers he is Greg Anthony how are you
Greg right back at you right back at you
would you make his ions debuted last
night sir I thought it was really
impressive you know particularly because
he was really good and what was always
perceived to be the biggest that's right
what's his perimeter shooting didn't
really display his explosiveness that we
all know he has and I think part of that
is we still getting confidence and trust
and you know he hadn't played in the
real game had any rules despise himself
but his field was what was most
impressive I mean the shooting obviously
was was huge but I thought his field
just the way he can make plays you know
the kind of team 80 years I think a lot
of positives take away from that and
then the bigger picture is the guy is
just exciting you know you're on the
edge of your seat waiting to see what
he's gonna do next and from our
perspective I mean you couldn't ask for
anything more
yeah I mean the it factor certainly
certainly showed up after a while and
the neat part about it is Greg is that
you know you're 19 you know you're on
ESPN you know you've got five points you
know your teams down at home by double
digits normally I mean not you couldn't
excuse a nineteen-year-old for just
folding the ten up and then in the
fourth quarter he just took it over
that was something I would take away
from that is that he's there there's no
give up that's a good thing to see even
though it's just one regular-season game
yeah you know his situation and you know
in a weird way I think could be very
similar to what he had a deep with RJ
Berry who Karen came in as the guy he
kind of long and radar a little bit and
was accepting of that and he still was
able to shine and I think with the
emergence of Brandon Ingram you know
who's a guy that they're gonna rely on
he shown that he's his ability to play
with other talents you know and not make
it about him that's so invaluable you
know as you're trying to build something
and I just think the pelicans are about
as lucky and I have to be about adopted
because one could be with a young team
about give me the best case scenario of
what you think you see ten games from
now from from him I think you'll see its
explosiveness back I think you'll see
him have a better feel for his teammates
that's the other thing that you know
like that continuity doesn't exist yet
and I think you're gonna see all that
stuff come to the forefront and I think
it's gonna be more aggressive you know I
thought early on II was a little
tentative which is expected I think the
kids gonna be a superstar in our league
and it's a breath of fresh air Greg
Anthony here on the Rich Eisen show ask
Greg Anthony you pull questions yeah
Greg so we're looking at which a young
superstar would you want for the next
decade so across over football
basketball Joe burrow to Zion and
jamaran Dyer what out there no I don't
even think it's close and that's not to
say that all those guys aren't going
somewhere a plan you know the difference
with him is he's got an equality that
you can't manufacture right you know you
just he's gonna do then and Josh got
some of that but I just nobody you know
nobody's come in with the expectation
and the height like a LeBron since
Tigers as an athlete and nobody in the
beauty of Tiger and the fire hoses two
guys that came in with all of that it
takes they actually lift up and probably
surpassed it and you know again Zion has
the capability to be that you know as
great as jaws been and and Burrell you
know they also in in burrows case he
doesn't necessarily control his own
destiny right we've seen great
quarterback talents though the bad
situations bad off its line for an
office the whole nine and they end up
not making it so I go with I'll go with
dying without a doubt and well is there
anything Zion can do you think that
could take the Rookie of the Year award
from Moran or no if you only play 40
games really even if he even if he goes
crazy like this for the net and he gets
stronger and he goes through like a ten
game stretch that nobody could even see
coming so there's nothing that could be
done
you know you got to have a certain
amount of points or shots or whatever to
qualify sure for title I feel the same
way about Rookie of the Year or an MVP
Greg thanks for the call we'll get you
back on when when you're not in transit
and we'll we'll give it a we'll give it
a good go thanks to the call brother
right back at you Greg Anthony Turner
sports for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app